[Music]
chicken breasts better than all the rest
chin breasts better than all the rest
chicken watch
like Nashville Tennessee that's where
I'm thumb is for Elvis yeah no use from
Memphis oh yeah alright this is chicken
watch baby in this series we're boiling
it down just a fried chicken we're gonna
try some Japanese fried chicken we're
trying taiwanese fried chicken we're
gonna try Jamaican fried chicken but
today we're going out there to see if
this natural hot chicken is the best
chicken in the world jig it wise to Kaz
you want to you want to like rise up
just to France do you guys know I hear
that yeah you're good awesome good I
like it
very creative hey how's it going how you
guys doing where'd you guys come from we
just came from the floor right but there
so what is Nashville hot chicken it was
a dish that was based out of revenge and
anger so guy comes home smells like
other women she smelled it and got
really upset so she's like all right I'm
gonna light him up I'm a Burnham burn
his palate don't want to touch your
Weiner with hot pepper he has xacti and
that's it it turns out he's that he
liked it so next day he invited his
friends over asked her to make it first
friends his friends liked it just like
no don't invite your friends over I was
trying to hurt you exactly because
you're hurting me it's like putting a
glass of water on a door and then the
guy opens in the glass of water stays
there like can you do this again for my
friend oh yeah Walker so yeah he invited
friends over and then they started a hot
chicken shack she's actually the creator
of this recipe chicken wouldn't be here
you know what yeah so this is really a
story about strong women yeah it for
sure we should do the point thing again
gigawatts - Katie
Oh stick in the ticket let the chicken
see stick in the dick and let the
chicken see sick and watch to K 18 so
you're gonna work with chef mat here how
do you make the fried chicken so it
starts with with sourcing really go
check with some nice hot sexy chicken
exactly he goes through a two-step
process it's basically like a dry wet
dry no bald spots no ball it's not the
bald spots no bald spot so it's like
braised in the fryer we're talking like
20 minute cook times okay no it's like I
was doing fine dining circuit 11 years
in the industry I was like you know what
I want to do my own concept life's short
risked everything to start eight
restaurants in Chinatown in Chinatown
which is also very confusing yeah we
need more chicken dreads we need more
chicken so much fried chicken back here
it's probably about like 160 people 160
orders before 11 a.m.
yeah we got drugged some more chicken
okay you're like a Ron gameshow Chris
how do you feel unqualified are you
getting in a groove now yeah kind of
okay okay you know what this is really
like soft jky to date
did somebody cheat on you Chris in there
oh yeah you'll see how this feels
this will teach you not to feel around
the sauce is made that you're gonna get
dipped in that and then what kind of
like apply different levels of heat to
it this is before this is halan and
we'll serve it in these little cute
boxes that we have right great
and then maybe everybody would join us
with some chicken wraps chicken wraps Oh
chicken rice flour cover it up and then
you get power you feed it to you beat it
like that you can just feed it on you
know I've never cheated on a girl before
so I've never been gonna eat a bunch of
[ __ ] how do we a rubric for Nashville
hot chicken moisture Chris penis sauce
you're the only ten I see this is really
a beautiful brain chicken why so we're
starting out with country this is just a
plain no sauce this is just good fried
chicken um but I'm gonna have to tear
off a drum the meat is falling off the
bone in fried chicken I've never seen
that before
well the flavor of the ham itself is
tremendous but it's not like that right
but it has a nice to it there's a kind
of sound effect
I'm bringing my mic next Thursday I know
what we're doing do you think that this
chicken is the only ten you see I don't
think this is gonna be the only ten I
see
mm-hmm I'm loving it but we're here to
try Nashville hot chicken so need to
turn up the heat it looks and smells
totally different and this is mild look
at how beautiful this chicken for my -
it's dripping with hot oil
now a spicy uh-huh now this oh no it's
gonna get so hot if this is my own so
some of the peppers were using just to
give you an idea the the the ghost
pepper is used to deter elephants from
walking across the fence they'll smell
it and then they'll just boom
turn around go the other way with this
mild and the second lecture net scorpion
that's used in Thailand and they
eliminate colonies of bacteria on boats
with it they clean boats with the spice
you put in your chicken I don't want to
go above that see you watch so this is
the medium in their sandwich their
sandwich has some of the sauce on it has
pickle sauce more sauce can a vinegar
slaw trying to maintain the highest
quality for everything that we're doing
we use a high grade French clarified
butter for our buns that's gonna talk
about highbrow low grab yeah oh wow
that's incredible with a slaw and this
balance oh this is like one of the best
chicken sandwiches I've ever this
sandwich is serenity I am also gonna
give this my sexy nod when it came out
and me and Keith sit into it for the
first time look at how beautiful alone
maybe than us is there something going
on between ice I don't know what should
we look for when we're tasting the
chicken obviously you're looking for the
heat buzz low the last yeah like they're
like exactly some people have that some
people will just literally quiet
yeah the spice buzz I was significantly
increased I'm Buzz Aldrin over here I
think I think this is where the fun
stops is this a glove woman do we start
putting gloves on down okay they gave us
this mac and cheese because they said it
helps with the spice first person to eat
mac and cheese is a loser just doing
wing oh oh I'm happy to be a loser okay
it's nice to lose
I wish my body worked only inhaling no
it's okay it was really got all over my
lips what happened
[Music]
oh it's all over go milk gasps a milk
I'm lactose intolerant you got milk on
the chicken and the milk like Vic the
chicken drank it girl it's bad a my
tongue man my time just [ __ ] up I got
a [ __ ] up Doug I do feel kind of
[ __ ] up I would like go do it in the
forest with like a group of good friends
this is the hottest chicken I put in my
mouth let's talk about the rubric crispy
this oh I guess the heat is there the
heat buzz Wow I think it's the same
amount of crispiness and juiciness I
just can't taste anything because as I
talk like my life I'm freaking out I'm
improving every how do you get spicier
than this how would you do that to
yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
next up very hot god by the way this
girl in line just now told us my friend
a Howland and he was in the bathroom for
30 minutes immediately and it said not
to have any coke I don't know what that
mean what does that mean I don't know
what that means
alright one hey I mean I was about four
up before even I mean you were about to
feel I'm scared don't be scared okay if
I'm doing it you can do it that's very
true I'm a baby
alright ready one two three chicken
watch
oh [ __ ] okay oh that is a different kind
of heat it's down it's actually a
different kind of heat okay oh okay what
it's at the back and laughs my mouth
it's on the back the back it's a
different heat what does that mean
okay oh it's like my tongue Steve Vai
tell your son to leave my house oh it's
getting worse ha ha so different peppers
affect the palate yeah so habanero is
like right here ah ghost pepper is like
right here it's like it hits you right
here
ha ha taking everybody well then when
you introduce secure line a reefer it's
actually up here too so brain it's in my
chest it's in my head as I'm talking my
body is like [ __ ] stop talking dude I
feel like my into my ears also it feels
like your scalp is coming up my body's
warm you okay
it's crispy okay I don't know [ __ ] up
the hi is evolving people [ __ ] up I
like blacking out of it
[Music]
but uh
[Music]
[Music]
Jelly Bellies they don't suffer me later
you Millie
[Music]
cookies and watch a movie
[Music]
I'm gonna be honest that experience that
was an experience like I understand the
miracle of childbirth better than before
yeah
part of me is thinking about doing it
again
this probably isn't a very good job I
feel great
feel relaxed I feel euphoric I feel like
I have a different sense of the world
man
my perfect tan is that sandwich because
it really just is all the element it was
what told me that that was a high-end
chef making a low-end food I would say
that chicken sandwich was the only ten I
see
it's hard because I actually kind of see
a few tens and different spectrums part
of my skin in my mouth to start
appealing chicken watch my chicken watch
Leslie do you think that this chicken is
the best fried chicken in the world ah
no because every different fried chicken
shop does a little bit differently your
hair is different than my hair right it
is that's the beautiful thing about life
is that everybody's different and then
everybody has these different qualities
to it and no one's really the best and
the one day you think you're the best
that's the day that you stop learning so
I want to keep learning on this sick
chicken what is this the best fried
chicken in the world who knows is it the
spiciest that we know this guy euphoric
experience I've ever had from chicken
yes I've never felt like this from fried
chicken it's like chicken watching with
your third eye you know we came here to
chicken watch at the end we chicken saw
I see you see I chicken feed
Higgins fees UK 18 a stick in the ticket
love the chicken see stick in the
[ __ ] let the chicken see chicken
watch 2k15
and we got our masters and eat it once
but it's a disaster put them in fridge
it gets bastard chicken bug no I'm
chicken plaster watch 2k 18